can we make it a social norm just bust
into song and dance like if I could bust
into song and dance at the best of times
and or the worst of times I feel like
life would always be rad I just need
Ryan Gosling's ABS crunches la-la land
so lala land is written and directed by
Damien Chazelle who directed whiplash
which was my favorite movie the year
that came out so it's really looking
forward to this one it stars Emma Stone
as a struggling actress in Hollywood and
Ryan Gosling is a struggling jazz
enthusiast also in Hollywood they meet
they start dating they start getting
creative to talk about their hopes and
dreams it's a dating movie it's romance
and song and dances in there because
it's also a musical which is a hard
thing to do man blending musical for
some odd reason people had it man well
Mary Poppins was coming out among the
musical era among Hollywood people knew
how to make musicals and recently people
have tried but never really hit what it
used to be
this is totally a love letter to those
old school movies with old school
musicals of old-school Hollywood and it
doesn't much better than movies who try
to do it now usually in a musical when
the movies happening and then the music
starts I'm always like I was kind of
jarring it didn't really flow well this
one is very seamless very well done the
music starts up in a very organic way
where you feel like people were in that
situation I totally think they would
start song and dance why wouldn't they
like I said hard to do which is one more
talent that we can chalk up to Ryan
Gosling my god man slow down give me
none left for the rest of us the dude
looks like that he plays piano I heard
he plays violin violin I can play the
radio and I can do this take that
Gosling Hey
and I've dogs that bark all the time
Emma Stone or Ryan Gosling really do
have great chemistry in here they work
well together they're cute together it's
actually a very believable romance and
believable relationship among a world
word musicals happen and the musical
numbers generally you're looking for the
splice you're like all right where's the
same kind but it's constructed in a way
where it looks like one shot worked for
Birdman worked for phantom pain works
for this and it is a sweet movie about
hopes dreams compromise ambition
relationships but also the reality of
that situation and it concludes in a
very rare and satisfying way I guess
Damien Chazelle what I love about what
he does is he incorporates music
with his movies in whiplash he doesn't
hear the music is very much a character
among the characters in his film and I
like that I mean after watching this
movie I was like I feel like I know a
little more about jazz and I appreciate
it I want to go to a jazz club right now
I will say most people can find
enjoyment in this movie but they'll find
it at different levels for different
reasons and I loved it it's a love
letter to old-school Hollywood musicals
which makes it almost a blueprint for
musicals now where it's like hey you
want to make a musical here's how you do
it and make it work I thought the movie
was very sweet very well done I will say
la-la-land is certainly worth watching
and worth buying on blu-ray I'm gonna
have to change that rating one day like
would people stop buying blu-rays just
download stuff hard copies folks hard
copies and this video is brought to you
by Adam tickets thanks to them for
supporting the channel this is actually
really cool alright so you download the
app and from there is pretty much a
one-stop shop for people who want to go
watch movies the app is free and when
you download it you can buy tickets for
yourself buy tickets for your friends
pre-order your concessions if the
theater has a sign stating you pick your
seat BAM walk in beep they beep a little
bark out on the phone go sit down enjoy
all for the sake of avoiding lines
because Lions suck if you're
procrastinator like me yeah you just
wait till the last minute then you get
there you guys stand in lines and you
get your movie late it's a really cool
app so you can follow a link below
download the app with promo code
Jeremy save yourself 5 bucks off your
next purchase on Adam tickets avoid
standing in lines and aging for nothing
okay so la-la-land have you seen it what
did you think of it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]